hello and i'm not doing it what's up
reject nation greg john and this guy ace
i was like oh let's get a star wars
expert on here hated everything he did
last time he was here and that's all his
positive comments and i was like fine
you can come back it's your privilege to
be here you're welcome you're welcome i
tried we make you look good
all right
no matt thanks for coming back i
actually watched his channel for the
first time after he plugged it here it's
pretty good go
i keep typing in first cut that's not
what it's called it's called first coat
it is called first cut we're going film
cut that's why we're getting wrong yeah
yeah yeah and i got it i gotta write
today obviously anyway guys we're gonna
watch episode three of obi-wan i'm very
excited for where we all are and yeah
full length watch longer as we sync up
with the time code are available over at
our patreon for super sexy rejects
reaction highlights and watch along is
included at the same tier for some
exclusive shows as well if you can't do
that use the force to hit the like
button it doesn't you really require
much for it but do it and also subscribe
and click that notification button
notified when our next reaction for
obi-wan is up and thanks to the boys of
prepper probably set down these
highlights thank you to you too for
listening to me ramble and also uh
follow ace on uh
film film theory all right let's get to
[Music]
yeah
it
don't make me kill you
i do not fear the dark
side through the lies of the jedi
it's like watching the terminator get
assembled is this a daily process for
darth vader it must be oh we can't get
darth vader
been looking for you for a long time
[Music]
he's coming master
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] vader's castle
[Laughter]
i love it
i have been watching you
third sister
prove yourself
and the position of grand inquisitor
is yours
[Music]
fail me and you will not live to regret
it
sorry yes sir
it looks so good oh this is what we
wanted just obi-wan invader
can't you make this thing go any faster
it's a trade route layer i'm not in
control of it
can't you use the force on it or
something that's not how the force works
that's not how it works
have you ever been afraid of the dark
how does it feel when you turn on the
light i feel safe
it feels like that
drugs make me feel that way
we better get ready
we're on approach
it feels like cinematic cutscenes from a
good star wars video game this whole
show feels that way to be
coordinates say the meeting point is
further north
that is if our new friend was telling
the truth why would he lie people are
not all good leia
damn snapping seems like a losing battle
these days
whoa oh he is
people aren't all good
stay close
this performance is so good so layered
really good
have you guys played uh
jedi paul on order yeah i was gonna say
i know something once in a while
i know star wars
i know this place
this is dope though it's crazy sick
now it feels especially like a cut scene
from a video here
i traced the manifest we should send out
all remaining probes now you
are not in charge here
oh
that seat is mine
not yours it's already sitting inside i
just spoke with lord vader he asked me
to lead the hunt
send out the probes do it
now
i will get what i deserve
and so was you
i will have two chairs
i certainly hope so
i'm getting to think they really killed
off the ground inquisitor
i'll be back
[Music]
or it was all a big part of the plan to
get them oh yeah
get the wheels turned in here
it's a cool call back to uh empire
with the probe droids being shot out
never seen that one
maybe they're just late i never should
have trusted him we don't know if maybe
no one is coming here leia
well if we're on our own we're gonna
need some help
what are you doing
[Laughter]
leia the hitchhiker we're looking for
the nearest port well i'm going that way
jump in oh no that's all right thank you
we just need directions come on father
we've walked long enough
thanks frank my pleasure hop in i can't
wait to eat them are you trying to
figure out whose voice it is yeah who is
that i have no idea it almost sounds a
little like jeff garland but it sounds a
little like seth rogen too well seth
rogen yeah
bob chapic but i doubt it
personally came down
[Music]
oh great
play chill man
oh god
[Laughter]
they're moving us around
looking for a jedi i hope we're not in
any danger oh no we'll find them we
always do
we're smart
[Laughter]
it's not like he's wearing jedi rose
we always hit our target boy he also
says with a little girl probably
wondering
hey you two haven't seen anybody match
that description have you
what are you doing out here
that's a long story
it's a long way
that sucks see the place where he met my
mother
of course she
she's not with us anymore do you have
any information about a jedi
i would know one if i saw one are you
sure he's even on this planet they know
what they're doing there
ugh you called her leia
i thought her name was luma
oh you listen that was her mother's name
i get confused sometimes when i look at
luma
i see her mother's face
we all miss her very much hmm that was
the truth just keep your eyes open
reported if you see anything and i'm
sorry for your loss
i'm not crying you're crying
that was not a long way
[Laughter]
are you my real father oh i wish i could
say i was
but no i'm not
sometimes i try to imagine what he was
like
he's a great guy as jedi were taken from
our families when we're very young
i remember a baby a baby yes i think i
had a brother
i really don't remember him carl kenobi
rick
can we get off here oh it's a standard
inspection don't worry won't take long i
know these fellas
before they
a couple of strays i found i thought you
might want to check them out
let me make myself look more like a jedi
where are you headed
uh back to tall
we have family here we were visiting all
right step out of the vehicle
initiate protocol 23.
um
[Music]
[Applause]
oh no
put it down
all right i'm putting it down nah you
can't hit her dude i'm putting it down
just
let it go
pretty sure you still could have gone
around it on
oh god
awesome
i mean
get down get down
i thought he was going to go nuts
put your head down
she's one of them
wow here we go they'll have sent a
transmission we have to hurry
i'll take you the rest of the way love
interest i'll inform lord vader he's
already been informed
he was most
appreciative he gave me his number
but we both know he'll be standing by
his side when this is over
the actual grand inquisitor
nobody goes in or out do you understand
me
go
the bickering quality does feel plucked
out of rebels he gave you the right
coordinates i was on my way when the
probes arrived but you'd already gone i
hadn't expected anyone to come
that's cause you're being negative
i didn't mean to run away
i used to do it all the time i just
it was just for fun it wasn't your fault
oh
l0la 59.
well less say hello
uh he's he's just a loader they don't
allow them to communicate
but what if he has something to say
appreciate how much he loves respects
the life of droids so much i really like
that aspect you're not the first jedi to
come through here
it all leads to jabim
from there we give them new identities
and get them out
[ __ ] i witness protection quinlan was
here yeah he helps now and again
smuggling youngling wow
that's a call back
quinlan boss father of eric boss from
new rockstars yeah definitely
great man only when the eyes are closed
can you truly see
see what
the way this is the way
open up in there
i said open up you get back into
meditating open up now
i think this church is going to go ahead
it starts to mess them up master chief
jedi was seen entering this camp
you seen anyone
hey
i'm talking to you oh my god yes do it
doesn't understand
come on
let's try the next one
kick your ass man
kick your ass
he's like you're lucky mess you up dog
compromise
we're coming to you right now i don't
care
get the [ __ ] ready hurry she's in game
of thrones mm-hmm opposite pedro pascal
yeah yeah
trying to place it yeah she's also in uh
luther why do you do this
risk everything i joined up when the
empire stood for something
by the time i realized what they really
were it was
too late
i made some mistakes
we all did
it's a fascinating role
what is it
he's in your mind
oh
no
oh wow
oh we're making a house call
where's that video
sound
this is cool i love seeing him like
on another planet
[Music]
wow this is such a mind [ __ ] for
[Music]
obi-wan hmm
oh my goodness
whoa
oh
awesome
you think he's trying to call him out
yeah he's trying to miss people
jump in and help yeah yeah yeah i think
he's gonna do it
promise me oh damn
i take them away
damn bro this is
amazing
[Music]
dude he is so sick he's like forcing his
hand he's sadistic
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh here we go
[Music]
oh man it's lit that thing up in a long
time just do it
i want him to do it so bad dory he's
running for the perfect moment to do it
yes
he knows just as well as we do it's
gotta be a good moment
[Music]
that was perfect actually
he did it so crispy man
come on balance yourself out man cook
him cook him
you have to help him he'll be fine
nope he won't be
i can make it on my own from here
oh
the ears have made you weak
he's just like taunting him
go
keep running till you reach the port a
pilot will meet you there
oh a fad film coming to life man
you should have killed me
when you had the chance
[Music]
forced aside for you everyone thought he
did
this is like a gold mine for an
inquisitor
oh
god damn
[Music]
he really wants him to burn like he did
wow
your pain
has just begun
surprising looking all right in that
fire yeah so far
bring him to me damn
oh
clutch droid
it's so cool seeing him through the fire
that uplighting like a monster movie i
do like seeing vader capture through
this camera work so much it looks really
cool it's really really cool man
[Music]
that's a cool shot
that all right flames the eyes damn this
is a pretty brutal ass vader it's the
punishment vader you're going to be okay
oh i think rival's gonna
get her don't be afraid yeah
come closer
are you the one i'm supposed to meet
unfortunately they couldn't make it but
i'll take you from here
oh
damn
[ __ ] damn that was great i really i
really
was a great one that was a great episode
i only took four people to write that
[Laughter]
that was a really great episode yeah
yeah best one so far yeah this was the
show i've been watching
yeah i know you love everything in
anything star wars this is the episode i
was like yeah this is the show i've been
wanting right here
i still love the first one but this is
this is another great one yeah it's on
it's not another level of me
now this compared to the other two
oh wait wait vivian letter player
moses sing group
son kane constantly saying his lines
differently every time
oh snap she's right killstead from zac
braff
is that who that was yeah i could hear
it now yeah
james earl jones
that's great james rowe jones and hayden
christensen may be in the suit
hey pedro pascal's barely on that set
director photography
that's uh the korean guy
i forgot what movie he did
but that's why he looks so cool cause he
was uh he was the one they they hired
years ago
man i'm gonna look him up right now if
that's okay with you guys um whoa whoa
it's not like it's not like we're gonna
jump cut here
must be within your brain
all right
no that's not him
[Laughter]
we'll come back with that information
and high four
three definitely
what all right gang dudes my dudes that
was a
really satisfying episode this is
exactly what i wanted to be i'm covered
in cat hair right now i just had a cat
on me a moment ago um
but
i thought this was really gripping this
was exceptionally gripping
watching vader at this more brutal
standpoint is something that i wanted i
just want them to go even harder that's
what i found myself there like a harsher
drag them through blow their heads up
really good dude do something gnarly
just go bananas
i want to see like that version of vader
and i love this
you know we've seen aggressive vape in
terms of live action we've seen like
aggressive vader mournful vader
about this is like rageful vader yeah i
really like it a lot of like rogue one
right it felt like the rogue one
a little bit
well they had the rogue one fight but
more than just a fight like when he's
talking to riva
or just going through the town and
torturing innocent people just like what
that i want that obi-wan that rise out
of give me obi-wan you know come on out
like the crooked the crooked bad boy
coming through town the uh the next snap
the force neck snap
was cool so cool like some stranger
things [ __ ] right there
yeah that's what i mean i want to see
like more of that i i really enjoyed it
i think
you know evan mcgregor just keeps
killing it but really quick while we're
on vader
what i loved about the vader performance
is like yeah getting james earl's jones
voice james earls
james james is earl james
jones's voice and back um
how it's like getting that performance
uh but you can still feel hey i don't
know if it's hayden christensen always
underneath it but you can still feel
that version of anakin skywalker like
when you watch you know the original
trilogy you don't really get a sense of
you know the of a hayden christian sin
underneath the suit um or hating
christensen type even yet here you can
feel that and it elevates it that much
more
and i love the way they capture him here
because this is the first time you see
vader caught in this kind of camera
movement like a lot of this
just feels like raw you know a lot of
those are handheld and simple landscapes
at times um it feels like when you watch
those van films
that and this is i mean this
complementary wax cause you could
depending on the the tone or slang and
how you say it when you say fan film
that can sound like an insult i mean
complimentary wise of when you watch
those great fan films those grippy ones
and you're like damn this would be a
cool thing why doesn't disney do [ __ ]
like this and then this is the stuff
where i'm like yeah that's what i want
to see more of that you know like when
he's torturing obi-wan and the fire like
he just it's been 10 years he's just
like i hate my life
i need to punish this guy for what he's
done to me um it's awesome stuff
ace what happened hold on second last
time you hey she go second there's a
ghost
oh i go first okay um
yeah vader was incredible
i mean
the idea of vader touching down
and getting his hands dirty and doing
the dirty work and not just leaving it
to riva and the inquisitors was a really
cool concept too i love seeing vader in
this terrain something that we've never
seen before at least not in like canon
uh we've never seen vader like touchdown
on the planet like this before we've
obviously seen him in hoth when he came
down there for that brief moment which
is a cool moment on empire strikes back
and then for the rest of pretty much the
original trilogy we see vader on ships
and on different star destroyers but we
don't really see him touched down too
many times unless it's like a video game
or something so that was really cool for
me uh seeing the
lighting of the light
i don't know if you guys caught with the
lighting of the lightsaber oh yeah it's
really cool
illuminates this this just their
specific like yeah little surrounding
this like circle that we're in the
circumference room yeah uh to finish my
point that i was saying at the end of
the video chung uh chun kung chung
uh who
is the dp for old boy dp for the
handmaiden uh he did last night in soho
he did a lot of other movies but he is a
very very good dp that's why this
episode looked like [ __ ] yeah that's why
it looked incredible yeah
i really am convinced that's why it
looks so good because we have a veteran
uh director of photography doing the
majority of the shots so i felt like
that came out quite a bit when it came
to the lighting in the shot selection
yeah i bet freaking obi-wan even
mcgregor's performance like when he
when the first time he sees uh anik or
he thinks he sees anakin because he's
kind of like tripping balls there was a
whole realization of because he's this
whole time he's thought he's killed him
you know and
living with the pain of that and
everything surrounding him is just a
reminder of that this whole the whole
even though he thought anakin was dead
the birth of what the empire is he feels
i imagine that he feels like partially
responsible for for it before never
having had the foresight to prevent
anakin from going down that path and
what it led to and all that
so the first time he sees him and then
when he senses him when they're in
what's that planet called that they're
in at the end here oh my puzzle
mario puzo
[Laughter]
uh yeah and then that the that distorted
sidewinding shot of him it just looks
like he's about to faint like just
getting hit with the presence of anakin
like he could just feel it sensing it
um
i'm trying to hand this off to you
without taking over
john it's all good they've done it no i
think they've done i think my perhaps
favorite thread that they've put into
the tone of this show is that amount of
foreboding and dread
and
viciousness or monstrousness that comes
off of basically the the entire dark
side presence here and even two
i'll include the obi-wan because there
is such a buildup with you know the
igniting of his lightsaber but two i
mean we we've remarked on the previous
episodes how much they're not going hog
wild with lightsaber stuff they're
really making those things
you know they're they're making them
rewarding by building them up in such a
way where at first when like you have
riva and him squaring off it's just like
this monstrous buzzing force and then
here you have all that build up to them
finally clashing together and yeah this
onset of
of dread and of just disturbance within
that comes with the arrival and the
presence of vader like i like the subtle
hints there's better disturbance than
the force
yeah and i like the way i i believe i
can't remember where i heard this
clarification but i think it's in one of
the like the novelization of revenge of
the sith where they say like you know
obi-wan left it to the force as to
whether anakin would live or die there
and i like that you have this sort of
question it's like yeah he assumes he's
probably dead but he doesn't know for
certain and there's almost like this
ghost story
um
mixed little hint of just demonic
presence that comes with the entire
situation surrounding anakin and i think
the way that they captured him here
really it's like you said it puts you
there
in a lot of different ways partly due to
the handheld nature partly peering
through the flames they do a lot really
nicely with foreground obstruction to
make it feel like you are really there
looking at this you know person and also
too seeing somebody like obi-wan who we
have such an association with being this
warm
safe presence much like the force says
he describes here is actually not is
actually completely sort of on his heels
and is you know terrified in a way of
what is coming and i like even though
they're not making a huge big deal out
of it directly that yeah there is so
much disturbance within obi-wan right
now and that's one of the the main
highlight of the show for me i mean it's
been like vader being badass the whole
time every time vader's there i mean
like we can see invaders uh castle oh my
god oh so i have to talk about that
because that was so cool i mean the idea
of just like
zooming in on the lava and then working
its way up the camera working its way up
to vader's castle and obviously
we know about vader's castle we saw it
in rogue one as well but it's it's seen
it again and seen more of the inside of
it and seen the throne room which looks
incredible which has a view of
all of mustafar in the back almost like
he wants to like remember
and almost like
you know remind himself of what happened
and what he is and how he became what he
was been a motive for of his this entire
time yeah it really is kind of this
crazy concept of like the most traumatic
moment in his life is also when he
became who he is now which is vader and
he almost wants to live in that moment
and live in that planet
and it's just a really cool
set design and it's a really cool
concept to see that invader i think
that's what's making vader so compelling
this time around more than before for me
because vader's always been great but
what makes him especially compelling is
that
he's a character you could feel all the
pain and the tortured soul underneath
the suit this time around where normally
it's like you had hayden christensen's
performance
and then darth vader was just you know
badass
i mean there was other shades that you
would be getting like empire strikes
back and turn the jedi of course but
here this is like a real to merciless
performance here and then you back that
with obi-wan's resigned
performance
the or know mcgregor's what
and by the way you know i know i was
like a little bit critical of the
actress who played leia before because
it just more of the writing of the
character because i had a feeling it had
something more to do with that but i
thought leia was actually really great
this episode i really thought she was
great and and i liked that we got more
shades of her she felt way more human
and not just like
you know uh precocious child actor like
she felt like a real human character and
i i really sympathize with her i just
wanna throw that out really fast but um
well curious to get um anyone's thoughts
on this one the lightsaber fight here
because i think what a lot of people
might be expecting is you know like
revenge of the sith had one of the most
epic balls to the wall like a lightsaber
fight that just went on for like 45
minutes it was like just a crazy
choreographed fight and that's not where
we're gonna get um
maybe something close to that maybe down
the road but of course not the beginning
and i thought
what was cool about this reintroduction
of it because we were all like once
obi-wan going to ignite his lightsaber
and so much about uh you know when
discussing the force is so much about
feeling you know and when he sees ob uh
darth vader for the first i mean he's
confronted with darth vader you know
it's like he whip he holds up the handle
of the lightsaber or what do you call
not the handle what was that called
the hilt that's what it's called good
word uh the hilt of the lightsaber and
we think he's gonna ignite it but he
doesn't
and then he gets that instinctual
feeling eventually and does it without
thinking and that to me is more as
opposed to making this big grandiose
moment of when he does ignite it that's
more
uh authentic and in line with what they
when they talk about with the force and
i like the fight because it was so
emotionally taunting versus crazy
choreography like vader just exuded
power and dominance over him the whole
time it was just like
kind of bullying you know what i mean
yeah you watch obi-wan's struggle and he
even makes that remark like well you
really are in bad shape everyone which
you get the sense almost like even even
though i mean his goal obviously is to
bring him in and have you know whatever
you know uh way
he wants to punish him i almost feel
like there's a small hint of like
i mean i can't break in like this
you gotta rise to the occasion a little
more for the history that we both share
but two i mean just the way that they
like you said before the way that they
enhance the colors like i love as much
as people gripe about the shows on
disney plus especially being you know
very desert oriented and whatnot i
thought it was nice to have this fight
take place in sort of a neutral ground
from you know the last famous fight was
obviously mustafar lava heroes we have
the crystalline version of that just
sand but you also have the darkness with
which the actual glow can illuminate
things and i love the fact they let so
much of that play in just the sound
effects and in that glowing because you
have those two striking strong
complementary colors which is cool from
a filmmaking standpoint because you know
they had to light that put the
lightsabers in after but it's also just
a great visual color representation of
the clash at hand
yeah i mean the lighting is obviously
amazing when it comes to the fight
itself it's interesting because i keep
thinking about
timeline wise as far as what they're
going to do i'm pretty sure they're
doing two seasons right is that what
they said for this
i have no idea i thought this was just a
or it could be a word it could be a
one-off but but my thing is
two seasons okay so my thing is like
eventually we're gonna get to a point
where we see
a much more improved ob1
um because obviously i keep going back
to the line from a new hope but it's
important because it's it's a very
famous line
from a new hope as far as implying that
you know last time we faced you know you
were you were the master but now i'm the
master um so
he was says i'm but the luna but you are
the master um so for me it's like i get
that [ __ ] i know i messed up [ __ ] i
messed the whole thing up right now
uh but for me it's more like you know
eventually we are going to get an
obi-wan who is a little bit more
confident in who he is and his abilities
and again
if you've seen rebels you've seen that
scene with darth maul which eventually
shows that he is much more connected to
the force than he is now which obviously
he's very much out of shape but not
there but it still was a cool like
brief moment it was very one-sided but
it was still like a cool like little
brief moment of like
teasing what could be as far as if once
obi-wan is like you know in god mode
well i think what they're doing with
obi-wan that i find
really really cool like it really
started to click with me in this episode
because yeah we will get that ob
whenever we just have to would it make
sense if we didn't get it obi-wan down
that road and we have to see his arc um
because right now he is so like he is so
there's so much destitute he is so
resigned and he doesn't want he's like
snapping at leia left and right over
anything that's like hey this might be a
positive thing no nothing's positive
everything's evil in this world
everything that happens he just snaps um
he's lost all hope uh basically for
anything good because he's a shattered
guy right now
and
this is slowly putting him on little
paths
where he can regain that light
like you with the metaphor he talked
about we're like are you scared of the
dark and then the light comes on and you
feel safe and he's slowly get getting
that light back in him from interacting
with leia and then seeing um the the
path is what it's called
yeah yeah the yeah the play where they
find like force sensitive kids and or
like help help get people out of there
it's like smuggle uh you know it's like
the underground railroad you know
yeah
um so that sympathizers yeah so they
have uh so like seeing that and then
seeing who else has crossed paths there
what's so neat is that he's obviously so
traumatized by his experience that
happened with anakin skywalker that
through confronting through having to
confront vader through having to
you know go through these altercations
with him again
this experience is what's going to get
him to be back in tune with the force
you know facing his darkest
thing ever is going to be the thing that
brings him the light again and i love
that and it just has to go that path and
i'm okay knowing that or at least
having a good guest as to that and i'm
okay with that because that's just a
beautiful story to tell and and it does
it does reestablish as it necessitates
as a gap for obi-wan for a live action
that we haven't gotten from prequels to
modern day trilogy you know yeah and i
feel like a lot of it too is going to
come back to qui-gon which we keep
getting teased
uh throughout the entire season so far
we've had three episodes and i think
he's mentioned him in all three episodes
definitely talked to him yeah or tried
to attract him in the
attack of the clone's revenge
but but i feel like that's important
because i think that's going to help him
connect
to his next chapter and his next step
obviously you know force ghost but also
just connecting to the force in general
when it comes to his abilities and when
it comes to his contact with the force
um and obviously overcoming anakin and
overcoming
who he is as vader and and i think
i don't know i think coming to terms
with it right because i feel like by a
new hope he's come to terms with like oh
definitely anakin's gone this is vader
now i have to you know be at peace with
that and that's not all on me yeah and i
feel like a lot of that's gonna come
from qui-gon well i think he probably i
mean qui-gon left him with the response
the role to i'm dying you gotta this
guy's chosen one you gotta put him on
the path and he prob
he probably feels like he completely
failed qui-gon and that also haunts him
that's why i love you mcgregor's
performance here because
you know i know there's a lot of cool no
i don't want to get his whole debate on
the last jedi i'm sick of that [ __ ]
conversation and there's a lot of
debating about you know uh luke
skywalker and all that and how he was
portrayed and they do something kind of
similar here but
we can it it all makes sense based off
of everything we know that came before
the show you know yeah
this guy totally would be in this spot
in his life at this point yeah based on
what we know that's a very fluid
decision rather than a oh oh that's a
choice
yeah yeah definitely
and and two just like i loved watching
him and and the young actress who plays
leia like go back and forth too like
there was so such natural interplay
between them
like you brought up before i think that
really helped to kind of bring
everything together for that performance
too what do you think about ace
specifically
how do you feel about the inquisitors
because they're i like i was excited
about the inquisitors
i'm not a big fan of the way they're
being portrayed to be totally honest i
mean i feel like they're
they they feel like they're part of the
part of the cartoon to me you know yeah
but i don't know if that's a bad thing i
i kind of feel like that's kind of what
they're made for i don't think they've
ever necessarily been
the most badass yeah really bad
necessarily
i don't think they've ever been in any
kind of media that they've been in
unless it's grand inquisitor season one
of rebels that kind of felt like a big
deal but you know the other inquisitors
from there on were always like in teams
and tag teams or like in trios which
kind of make it felt like
you know if they were so imposing you
know one of them could be a big deal but
it's always in groups i i don't i don't
i feel like they're fulfilling the role
that they are tasked with and i feel
like they're doing a pretty good job
with that so i feel like i'm in the
minority of people who i've enjoyed riva
thus far and i did too i do too yeah and
i feel like in this episode
and i feel like the part of it is that
yeah i feel like the rest of the
inquisitors are a bit
you know like uh sun kang talks really
slow and king says every what which
brother is he again fifth brother
yeah yeah um
son kang he says every line the same
every eye every line it's a lot like
this
and it takes
a long time to get them all out and so
yeah like i i feel like in a way i'm
like okay that almost does feel like a
choice and yeah the rest of them are
kind of bickery and self-serving and
power-hungry and riva has a purpose
beyond all that and a connection to
anakin i just think her presence
i i believe the menace in her presence
or at least like the seething anger that
guides her she's not as scary as darth
vader but them together i'm like yeah
i'm a little threatened by them like
when she tracks down leia i'm like well
that's not good you know like whereas if
it had been sung kang i'd be like hey
it'll be fine yeah
leia can take sun king yeah not not just
light han or anything
how do you fee i mean i liked riva i've
been a back and forth on her performance
specifically but i liked her here on
this particular i liked everything about
this episode but what did you
think about what do you think is going
on with the grand inquisitor here do you
think that they're you just like this is
a thing that kind of mapped out with
vader to get to elevate the others yeah
i feel like this is just another like
while this guy is out of commission kind
of thing
we'll we can make a new grand inquisitor
if you fulfill the task and if you prove
that you're better than this guy but
obviously he's got to know he's not dead
yeah 100 100 for sure i just feel like
he's taking advantage of his like
leave of absence
granted inquisitor was supposed to go on
vacation anyways they're like we'll come
up with this ruse that way riva could
really rise to the right one
his uh his suspension
he's been suspended for a couple months
he's been written up
yeah he's you know while he's out we
need a new grand inquisitor to fill the
role
uh i feel like that's kind of what it is
and it's funny because i actually kind
of like that scene because it's also
very original trilogy vader especially
empire strikes back where he's always
trying to promote the next guy he's
definitely definitely he did it like
three times uh admiral pete shout out to
mlp
um but it's like
that's my boy
oh some guy out there with an emerald
t-shirt is just shedding a single tear
but i feel like that's uh that's what
vader does right he's always kind of
like the big boss
promoting people and demoting people and
killing people if they do a bad job and
it's like a running that was like a
running joke an empire like he kept like
killing off people and he kept like
promoting them and i i feel like this is
kind of what he's doing now with the
riva he's just the worst manager
all i know how to do is promote or kill
i don't know how to empower a team
i don't know what i'm doing guys i'm
just winging this
lord vader over here
darth vader can i go to the bathroom no
no
stay on the assembly line i will squeeze
your bladder
yeah
stranger stars
um yeah i mean i i don't really have
anything more to add but is there
anything i mean the shout out to quinlan
boss that was cool um you know you jedi
you're trying to refresh my memory
between takes and i was like i do
because i saw clone wars once yes really
quick watch yeah the only time i took my
time was the final season um that was
the time i i loved the final season but
i would like binge the [ __ ] and then i
just took my time in the final season
but i'm like so much of it is a blur to
me now yeah cuz i don't even like i'm
like that sounds so familiar i don't
remember quinlan moss yeah quinlan boss
um obviously clone wars a lot in the
comics if you guys are in the comics um
he
teamed up with obi wan to take on cad
bane that was a cool fight scene from
from clone wars 2.
um yeah i mean he has a connection
adventurous if anyone is connected to
that so if anyone knows about that
adventure's dead right
she's dead by this one yeah okay no
too bad i liked veterans i feel like we
can get calcastas now ooh yes because uh
this takes around the same time period
too i think so as far as jedi fall in
order to
yeah
yeah i think i mean like that's what
this this whole thing with the path was
like making me go oh [ __ ] man it really
feels like we're seeing the inquisitors
which was [ __ ] out of jedi fallen
order and then which is not
anyway but yeah but generally you have
that and then you have uh and then the
thing with the path like oh my god i'm
getting jet i fall in order fives right
now
has passed through there at some point
it would be great if we got calcastas
he's so that such a cool kid and then
they announced jed i fall in order too
and you know how disney is they're
trying to line all their [ __ ] up so yeah
i feel like that that would be great if
we can get calcasa i think that would
just make fans lose their [ __ ] that's
like the next stage right like we're
getting cartoon characters brought to
life now let's get the video game
characters that'd be amazing it'd be a
really cool like
you know shout out to anyone who plays
the video games because i feel like
that's a you know
media that doesn't really get
acknowledged too too much and i also
want to say really fast um even though
i've been critical of riva's performance
it has nothing to do with the fact
that she's black
i've been watching i went on uh social
media talking about heavy spoilers about
this and
apparently i've just been so blind if we
were talking about this before we filmed
i was like apparently i've been soap
because you've known about it for months
i've been so blind to all this like
crazy
amount of
sometimes people say it's racism when
it's like not people are being some
people are just critical of stuff and
then there's other part where people are
just saying straight up racist [ __ ] full
on racist [ __ ]
and
that [ __ ] just i don't know why we're
still there with a lot of the fan bases
star wars like this is [ __ ] bananas
to me that we can what is supposed to be
like just a bunch of aliens robots and
white people like you see yes
that's that's kind of what they want
yeah it's [ __ ] ridiculous and um i i
i'm rooting for moses it's maybe roofer
moses ingram that much more because
you'll see these some of these youtubers
thumbnails of the [ __ ] they say on them
i couldn't believe it
and uh
i think it's just so such a shame and
[ __ ] disgusting and
um and for all you star wars fans out
there who think you're on the rebel side
when you're doing [ __ ] like that maybe
reconsider your entire moral compass i'm
not talking about people who don't like
the character or like we're just like i
don't like the character i'm not a big
fan of performance that's like a
completely different conversation there
is some straight-up racism out there and
that [ __ ] just needs to end man
yeah i mean if i'm being honest i i feel
like
it's it's been a part of star wars
obviously for for a while now it really
stood out a lot when it came to the
force awakens
and john boyega's character uh there
came this huge wave of online
criticism towards
any
co-lead not even lead like just co-lead
black character that was a part of the
star wars franchise
and this stuff with moses ingram i
really encourage people
if you aren't a fan of the character or
if you are
a little bit more critical of the
performance to try and
not just give it a chance but to try and
reconsider
perspectives on
what comes from that right
is your perspective coming from a place
of watching the show or is your
perspective coming from any of these
online videos that you may be watching
because i do feel like that has an
influence and these online creators who
have a negative platform create that
negative atmosphere and can create a
negative perspective that's kind of what
happened with the last jedi sorry guys
um a lot of people came out of the movie
theater and they were like yeah that was
pretty good and then they saw videos and
they're like i don't like it anymore um
in fact i hate it yeah and i felt like i
i ran into so many people who reacted
like that and when it comes to this i
for one have always been outspoken as
far as
racist star wars fans which is a a part
of
the
for you know the franchise and the fans
and i feel like people saying that we
shouldn't acknowledge or we should
ignore this i don't think ignoring it is
the way to go i think acknowledging it
pointing it out and condemning it is the
way to go and as much as we want to say
that the majority of the fan base is not
racist we should still acknowledge that
there is a lot that are racist and they
are very vocal and very persuasive uh so
i really do encourage people to
defend moses anytime you get a chance to
really just stand up and to be on the
right side of this because come on guys
this has been
way too long and we cannot be standing
for this so yeah
yeah and i mean not every time
a person who's not a white person shows
up is some kind of mathematical you know
attempt to white men too
yeah white man is like if there's
anybody other than that there's some
kind of reason for uproar and sometimes
it's just like hey different kinds of
people exist and could fill various
roles and if you want a diverse galaxy
that really feels like it's of another
world where there's tons and tons and
tons of people and and species
overlapping
what's what's the problem it's it's i
hate the i just hate this part like we
make a lot of jokes uh about that side
of the
of that vocal part of the internet that
screams culture and everything
you know uh we make a lot of like
satirical jokes about that but
truthfully there isn't a lot of jokes
because that should just honestly annoys
the [ __ ] out of me it just it pisses me
off that the second they hear
of of somebody it that suddenly there's
an agenda but i'm like not one part of
this show has made about riva being
black to begin with like yeah it doesn't
even it's not even the point of the
character it's not like they're making
some social commentary about it that's
the thing it's like it's like wait for
the text of the thing you're complaining
about to actually be disingenuous in
trying to incorporate some kind of
progressive message before just decrying
oh my god they're ruining my favorite
whatever and for what star wars is about
to be to have racism so like about fans
surrounding it
is is like
anti-star wars to me it's the most
anti-service thing i don't know how many
times i have to say that if you are
very much
anti
you know
progress anti-progressive anti-scene
diversity then you are anti-star wars
sorry not star wars
star wars has always been about
overcoming
this empirical standpoint
of seeing everything uniform and
everything one way the whole point of
the rebellion and having freaking
characters like lando
be the one to take out the second death
star
uh with the freaking sullustan in nine
nub was to show these two guys who are
communicating in different languages and
still taking down the most powerful
machine on the planet that's that's a
very
very
progressive moment in star wars and i
feel like george lucas if you know
anything about george lucas or read up
anything on him you will know that
that is exactly what he's trying to
communicate so again that's not star
wars
yeah i don't i wasn't planning on
bringing that up but
just came out of here
like
this is a thing that's happening the
only people allowed to vanquish myspace
nazis are other white people okay
i'm just gonna say i think it needs to
be said
i will i i mean the last thing i'll say
is i think is the odd part about it is
people i don't think often realize
that's the thing with like a lot of real
racism is they don't realize that
they're being racist they just think
it's a point of view they have about a
certain thing
without realizing and then they blame
like agenda virtue signaling something
else without them realizing oh wait i'm
actually being pretty racist about this
right now especially with the fact that
i just said a racist thing right now
because a lot of it has been very overt
in in the way it's been said about her
that so much of the star wars freaking
social media had to come out and say
something i'm like because yeah it was
pretty bad
um oh yeah that tweet from the actual
star wars yeah
there was some like really nasty once i
saw like youtube thumbnails saying [ __ ]
i was like oh no this is ridiculous
anyway guys
um if you're not one of those people
subscribe to this channel
we just lost we go under a million subs
like how many people worth a lot of
racist subscribers
that's weird they must have all thought
you were white
[Laughter]
yeah no that is this is a star wars
video yeah
you never know i'd rather put that out
put that honest thought out there and
lose subs if that means we can get wean
out some of those people
um
but then when the camera's not rolling
oh my god the numbers are dead oh no
we have to go back
whoa culture's ruining everything no
good comments about riva from now on
guys okay
if you do have to talk about riva's
complaints only
all right we gotta do a patron of the
day shout out
chris wham-off coming in at the last
minute of may
thank you so much for pledging to our
patreon page again buddy it's been a
while since i've heard of you but i feel
like it's really fitting to shout you
out on obi-wan because
let's face it if there was someone who
really really really didn't
actually have the feelings to help out
someone
but
was asked to
and would do it because they were asked
to because they knew it would be the
right thing to do
it's 100 you
there's no one just that good a guy
you're just that good a guy you do more
community service work than anyone i
know that includes not just people on
patreon but anyone i know in real life
too
so chris it's great to have a soul like
yours at our patreon page don't don't
have enough people like you in my life
so
i'm grateful that you would support us
for as long as you have
and uh thank you for being you man and
um i hope one day we can't meet a person
where you'll treat us to dinner because
we're not you and
we are stingy i like to spend more than
like ten dollars
on another person on myself i'll spend
boatloads but on another person not much
money but for
for us you know like i know you'll treat
us good man i know you'll i know you'll
go on the negatives for us i know you'll
max out that credit card we deserve your
charity so thank you chris for willing
to go broke
to support us people who don't need your
money but we'll gladly just take it
because
we're us
chris
love you buddy
[Music]